a hologram of Ukrainian President Vladimir Zelensky,
cute dogs in the battlefield and destroyed Russian tanks put on public
display.
Ukraine has been able to galvanize domestic and global support with propaganda tailor
made to go viral.
It's managing to make its case that it's the underdog operating a defensive stance against the
Bullying,
aggressive,
here's what a 21st century pr campaign looks like during a war and how raising
global awareness has helped Ukraine secure funds and weapons to fight off Russia's invasion.
From the early days of war,
Zelensky has been busy addressing global leaders,
becoming the face of the country's resistance in the span of about three months,
he virtually attended about 40 events the end of this war and its
circumstances depend on the world's attention.
He is the leader of his people in a kind of David versus Goliath
situation.
Paul Bains has been monitoring keys propaganda tactics throughout the conflict.
He says,
getting Ukraine's most well known figure in front of the world's most influential people at high profile
events is an effective way to keep the public interested.
He's well aware that this is a long haul over time when it's no longer
newsworthy.
Western might forget about his communications are designed to ensure that doesn't
happen.
One consistent message in many of Zelensky speeches has been the call for more weapons
and by mid june,
the US has supplied more than $5 billion worth of weapons to Ukraine on top of other
military support from Western allies.
Zelensky has also been tapping the power of celebrities.
For example,
in early May,
he invited pop rock band U two frontman bono and guitarist the edge to visit
Ukraine.
They performed in a subway station turned bunker with a soldier who fronts one of Ukraine's biggest
pop rock bands.
These sorts of invites and meetings have also
coincided with Zelensky efforts to raise financial aid.
The same week as Bono's visit,
the government launched a website that would be the country's main venue for donations,
raising more than $136 million by early July
one key part of Ukraine's 21st century propaganda
toolkit is social media to resonate with the younger generation.
Ukraine's official twitter account has been covering the latest from the war through art to boost morale.
Those living in Russian occupied cities as well as hashtags and memes about
weapons.
Ukraine's Ministry of Foreign Affairs has also posted content of animals in the battlefield to
soften the image of the military.
One of its most popular mascots is patron the de mining
dog that received a military medal from Zelensky.
It appeared on the Canadian prime Minister's twitter feed and the dog's own Tiktok account had
nearly three million likes.
By early july it's got a dog or a cat today.
It's much more likely to go viral but leads to this cuteness of course,
is the message that we're picking up these weapons.
We have the ability to de mine our country and so it's another
symbol of resistance.
Zelensky is instagram has also been featuring ads like this.
It shows a montage of people at a gas station.
Yeah.
Mhm.
The video goes on to say that eu countries that continue to import Russian energy are funding
Moscow's war efforts and killing Ukrainians.
This post was viewed more than four million times since early april.
It's one part of Ukraine's ongoing efforts to isolate Russia economically and in May,
less than two months after that video was released,
the European Union pledged to ban 90% of Russian oil imports by year,
end.
many of the videos released by Ukraine are heavily produced like this one using color filters.
They have an increasingly well developed film industry.
If you've got the quality of the production of film released through social media and
it's much more likely to resonate with the people that it's aimed at.
To keep up its resistance against Russia.
The Ukrainian government has also been galvanizing domestic morale.
So it's been turning some incidents into propaganda opportunities.
For instance,
releasing stamps showing the sinking of a Russian warship.
It's a very clear illustration of a nation's kind of authority
really,
what he's saying to the people is we are still in control,
we're beating the Russians.
One way to show that Ukraine is putting up a fight against Russians is to display their destroyed
military vehicles in public or in a museum where visitors can take a closer look at
war.
Paraphernalia like uniforms worn by Russian soldiers.
The Ukrainian government told the Wall Street Journal it will continue to seize every opportunity and use
creative methods to keep the world talking about the war as long as it rages on
Ukraine,
as well as Russia have not slowed down their push for support at home and abroad.
The difference is that Ukraine has the support of the West and Russia doesn't.
Therefore,
Russia's only really able to use its propaganda on its own
people.
And unlike much of the world,
many of those inside Russia remain out of reach for Ukraine's ongoing Pr campaign.
Yeah,
yeah.